All right. I sent my labs in for you to take a look at. There was a message from late last week over the weekend. We were on vacation with our daughter's family and did a lot of walking yesterday morning. I woke up with a tender spot on the front of my shined a hip bone front of my hip bone.
Today, not as sore, but it is a bit inflamed larger than the other side felt great to walk and be active. Oh, it is kind of strange that is sore up there, almost like bummed or bruised it, but I didn't any thoughts.
I couldn't imagine, you know,
just it depends on where it is. So it's so what you have to be careful, if you have metastasis to the bone is you have to be careful of weight bearing exercise.
If it's metastasized to a part of the bone that is a weight bearing bone and it's a particularly weak part of a bully structure, then you'd have to be careful.
So that to describe if a person has metastasis to the neck of the femur. So you've seen a femur bone where they come up because if you are sitting down right now and you put your hands on your knees, that thigh bone is your femur bone.
It comes up and then angles inward as it attaches with the ball to what's called the acetabulum joint in your pelvis, well, that little neck, which where it takes that angle is the weakest part of the bone.
So in a person fractures their hip, they have a hip fracture, as people age, it is actually because the neck of the femur fractured because it was weak because of osteoporosis, typically, and that hip fracture. Now, if this person who asked this question, if they're paid as way up there, then that's a concern.
If it's central femur area, that's not a concern, because the typically, unless you have a great degree of metastasis to the central part of the femur bone, it's probably the strongest bone in your body, not at the neck of the femur, but the central part of the shaft of the femur bone is the dead system, strongest part of the body.
If the last pet scan, it was a recent pet scan, and there was no metastasis to the femur, the neck of the femur whatsoever, or the pelvis, then I wouldn't be concerned. Now, you can't have referred pain from bone, you can get deep bone pain, but you can also get referred pain to what's called the dermatome, which is the skin surrounding the area.
And it will be a neurological referral, the acetabular area, the neck of the femur is integrated by, I think, L3, maybe L3 or L2, that's your third or second lung bar, and the front of the thigh is integrated by L4.
Certainly, if you had the metastasis to the lung bar spine and walking, because you're doing this weight barrier exercise, and you're walking, if it was irritated, if you have, if you have a metastasis to L2, L3, or L4, it could refer pain along that dermatome, so you could have, it could be referred pain is what I'm saying.
So yes, when you have cancer, you tend to think everything is related to the cancer.
But and that is not true, but it should be, no, we don't want to be worried, so it should be your first go to that, is this referred pain from metastasis to the bone, and the only way to really rule that out is to look at a PET scan, or CT scan of the bone, if that was done recently, an X-ray of the bone is much less invasive, but it's, you're not going to see.
Bouldy destruction of tellers at least 50% bone destruction of an X-ray where you'll see that much earlier at a CT scan in the earliest on a PET scan.